hello everyone
welcome to
rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
and today i'm with my youngest son hans
hey and uh we're gonna
carry you today here together
uh anyways i'm gonna be covering a
couple things one of them a little bit
subject down extinction
probably won't stay there very for very
long then we're gonna address a couple
issues uh related to the flat earthers
uh we still haven't resolved
an important issue there that i need for
them to understand especially what the
problem is what the question is
and we're going to do a little bit of uh
existence today we're going to find out
what existence is
person asked question about that
and then i'm going to address the
um
critic science critic that criticized uh
my
notion of rational science
and we're gonna open the floor up four
questions
okay so let's get started here first i
just want to say i had a little bit of
kobit
uh still have my
nose clogged
still have my nose clogged a little bit
but
because of that i went to get a third
shot against kovid okay and it's a
shot of havana club okay doctor
recommended yeah good for the throat
okay yeah i'll always recognize
always recommend a shot above honor club
is that why your theories all come out a
little sideways well before or after the
shot that's the question see
okay so let's get on with this um issue
about extinction uh in our channel we
say that man is
very
soon to become extinct what
we're not that far away from extinction
yeah uh as uh
as a race as a species so i think that
notion is kind of propagating itself
around like everyone kind of feels it in
the air but no one can put their finger
on it yeah yeah i think that's true and
and some of that you know it reflects on
the number of movies the number of books
that that have been written on the
subject in the last maybe 50 years you
know lots of people writing thinking
about you know extinction some say it's
climate change others say well we can't
support a growing population there are
many reasons but there's a feeling in
the air that people say well something's
not quite right right
okay anyways um these are the reasons
men will not become extinct okay
and uh jesus returns well
they have all kinds of things you'll
find uh maybe one of the ones you heard
uh or the one you uh champion in there
and i'm saying none of these have
anything at all to do with the
extinction of man in fact they had
nothing to do with the uh any mass
extinction in the past
okay so asteroids comets you know uh
volcanic activity etc etc none of this
caused the extinction of anything in the
past
and one of the problems i've got is with
these survivalists and preppers you know
survivalist is a guy who likes to be a
boy scout he goes out into the woods and
wants to hunt some animal he wants to
live off the land in that sense
and i don't think that's going to happen
because we're going to probably wipe out
all animals before we go so there will
be nothing to hunt
taking them with them we're taking them
with us we're all going to heaven
together and so there will be nothing to
hunt out there as far as the preppers
are concerned a lot of these people
think that they're just going to
plant whatever you know gardens and
they're going to teach their neighbors
how to plant etc etc they don't realize
that they're going to be swamped people
from the countryside
especially from the cities they're just
going to overrun their lands
and they won't be very friendly when
they're very hungry okay and so
you know i don't think none of that's
going to happen
as far as them being able to
farm and hunt the way they think they
they will and a lot of them are
preparing in that sense they say i'm
gonna get my gun and i'm gonna go out
there and hunt deer and i don't think
it's gonna happen okay what's gonna
happen according to this side at least
is there's gonna be an overturning of
the ecological pyramid
a mass extinction is the pure
disappearance of a what food chain okay
so it's got to do with food we starve to
death the majority of the humans will
starve to death that's our argument here
okay and i've covered it in the past i'm
not going to go into any detail
today all i'm going to say is here's uh
one
bit of evidence if for those who are
interested in evidence the in the last
60 years the growth uh
the gdp growth this is for the united
states um has gone down and down and
down okay so we're
the united states which is the biggest
empire on earth is growing
at an ever uh slower rate okay so that's
the that's what the graph shows
part of that reason is or behind that is
that you know the population on earth
has not been expanding okay not at the
same rate as it was in the past so we're
still growing but we're growing at an
ever slower rate and we're reaching the
asymptote where we're actually growing
asymptotically
and so it's not going to take long
before we reach zero population growth
which is we reach a plot plateau
uh on earth
and why is that important in terms of
economics well because you know in
ultimately it's demand
you know population is demand so you
have no population you have no demand
and those who are alive and already have
built their uh lives they already have
houses cars everything they need more or
less they just replace some of those
items you know every now and then but
it's not like you know when the car came
out for the first time telephone came
out for the first time you know then
they sold a lot today we're in the
replacement mode at best and only the
new generations create new demand
okay so uh what's uh
one of the followers out there he put a
question here okay or he put in uh an
issue he says do you know that there we
will be pretty cold this winter in
germany
uh yeah and uh it's because you know uh
mr putin he kind of turned off the valve
to the gas to germany and europe in
general and united states has stepped in
to try to see if they can conquer that
market but it can't and so the question
is whether that pipeline will open up
again before winners uh here you know
because uh we're gonna need some
uh energy right and apparently the best
way the cheapest way to supply it is
directly from uh russia but because of
this war in ukraine that's not happening
for the moment the question is whether
that will change from here on in the
next few months
and so let me give you a little bit of
input on that first here's a
little article from the new york times
okay it says
europe a big market for the uf for u.s
corporations could have a nightmare
winner if natural gas prices continue
rising okay
so germany is in trouble
europe is in trouble because uh they
have all these energy prices rising okay
and supply chains are still
dysfunctional for many companies meaning
they can't even make and sell products
for which there is demand all those
headwinds that created the downturn
meaning ukraine right primarily and
coveted right they're still intact and
arguably getting worse
uh and so the question is
uh is that going to be solved from here
until the end of the year
and all i can give you is uh my take on
a little thing that's going on right now
in the public domain that they've kind
of shoved into the public domain and no
it's not ukraine ukraine is falling from
the public domain nobody's reading too
much about that nobody knows where
ukraine is or cares about it there's
another issue it's got to do with
celebrities it's got to do with the
midterm elections and here it is they're
trying to do a spy swap or you could
call it a hostage
swap
and essentially i think this uh deal
with this uh
lady you know the
rainbow gal that's over there
in russia arrested you know she's not
important at all but they made her
important because i think the united
states wants to have dialogue with
russia again
you know more or less everybody's
accomplished their goals russia has
conquered the donbas which is primarily
what they wanted uh the united states
has conquered germany and france without
firing a shot so they're happy with that
as well so everybody more or less has
what they want
but the issue is this pipeline you know
germany needs a little more gas from the
east the united states doesn't like it
but at the same time recognizes the
needs of europe so they might have to
open that thing up or allow for it to
open it up and i think this uh swap
has something to do with that and not
with the celebrity but people uh respond
to celebrities and uh it surely would
help mr biden if he wins the midterm
elections and so if he can get that gail
out of there right and show some
progress in that sense
uh republicans obviously can't oppose
that and say no keep her in there you
know and so i think that's what that's
about russia would again get the donbass
probably or some deal with ukraine uh
they would have peace they they probably
want peace they probably can't continue
with the war and they also have problems
with their economy the united states has
problems with its economy and it's got
this inflation wants to stop it's got
the midterm elections so i think
this swap has to do with opening up
channels again
under that excuse which uh everybody
more or less can
uh you know agree that that's a good
deal so they're probably gonna open up
talk
uh go to a negotiation table there
something's gonna come out of that and
uh maybe biden gets his midterm election
maybe he gets a better control of his
economy the russians get uh control of
their economy maybe they don't suffer as
much through the war maybe the war dies
down a little bit maybe they reach an
agreement i think it's going to go in
the direction of peace of you know the
politicians and the uh
ministers of uh
uh exterior you know are gonna resolve
these issues i think either way we're
gonna be wearing jackets in the winter
okay let's move on to another subject
and that is the flat earthers and i like
to show this up front okay
yeah this is the brain of uh an
intelligent person he's got a cpu and
the flat earther usually has a rom or
read on only memory that's essentially
the difference he just reads and that's
it is this what you spend your time on
anyways isn't even a point here well
yeah it is a point because they're not
very intelligent people they're like
that was the point that was a point yeah
you had to draw a picture yeah
uh a picture is worth a thousand words
but even so i i have been on i am on
record the flat earthers are 10 times
smarter than relativists and mechanics
because see these guys went to the
university studied for 10 years and they
come out saying stupid things like you
know space time black holes dark energy
uh big bang you know they come up with
all this nonsense a particle can be at
two places at once they have all so much
garbage
and
worse than that they believe in the flat
universe theory
so you gotta hand it to the flat
earthers at least you know these people
are usually ignorant people who never
went to school or went to high school
maybe at best uh
you know and they do the best they can
with whatever knowledge or education
they've got compared to the relativists
who've gone to 10 years of school i
think they're a lot smarter
they're more skeptical it seems yeah at
least
they have a little bit of doubt and that
keeps them rolling whereas the other
people have no doubt whatsoever they're
just brainwashed directly
yeah they're pretty much by the new gen
by the old generations and they just
accept it on the basis of authority
that's the problem okay so in that sense
flat earthers smarter than math
magicians i'm on record okay so yeah
anyways uh here's um
[Music]
how i started this problem a couple
weeks ago and it is that you know when
when a car moves forward and you have a
balloon
just standing still
the balloon doesn't move backwards like
you would you know if you accelerate you
get flat against the seat you're pushed
against the seat that's not what happens
to a balloon balloon goes exactly the
opposite way it goes forward you mean a
helium balloon uh well it could be an
air ballon one also it doesn't matter uh
in a gas balloon okay but why does it go
forward well the theory is that the air
inside the car
moves backwards or stays there
and because the volume of air is is
greater behind the balloon that's what
pushes the balloon forward and here's an
illustration of that here's a you can
see how it the car accelerates and the
balloon goes forward instead of going
backward which is kind of
counterintuitive okay it works with
helium
there
uh no it works with air as well because
of the volume but be on the ground
uh no
an air balloon yeah yeah yeah that's uh
they just inflate it with uh
yeah it doesn't float
well it's tied to the ground okay so
yeah but it'll still go back an arable a
balloon full of air just oxidation just
if you blow into it it doesn't float but
it has less density than normal here
if you blow a balloon it'll go up you
know yeah i mean you've never had a
what you've never had a birthday perhaps
if you just blow a balloon it goes to
the ground unless you hit it up and then
it just slowly falls down again yeah
okay yeah yeah you're right about that
but uh maybe it was a healing building i
don't know but the point is that this
balloon instead of going backwards which
is the way
everybody but you know that's our
intuition it moved forward okay when the
car accelerates okay maybe it was a
healing balloon i don't know i didn't
check but the point here is uh the
explanation is that egg moves to the
back or stays in the back of the car
there's more volume of air and that's
what pushes the balloon forward that's
the theory okay so that's where we're at
okay so what happens here
um didn't you equate it to an air blue
air bubble in in the water well yeah
yeah i did that as well but uh let's
move on to
uh what the issue is because people
don't understand the question i'm asking
okay especially the flat earthers they
do not understand the question
and and that's been at least three times
which i put the question they still
don't understand it and so this fellow
says the follow up well hold it
this is just another version of that if
a car accelerates or you're on the bus
or you're on the subway and the subway
accelerates you get pulled backwards
okay
and the question is what's pulling on
you or what's pushing on you why are you
moving backwards when something
accelerates that's the question okay
and uh and right now people are having
problems lots of problem understanding
the question they officially black uh
flat earthers they do not understand the
question so i'm going to clarify the
question
so that even a flat earth i may
understand that i don't know maybe maybe
um
i've got my hopes up let's find out here
it is okay uh one file says the
following he says let's see if i can
shed light on the million-dollar nobel
prize-winning question what causes the
air to go back yeah that's the question
he says structure
okay let's see what he knows about this
he says all the car parts which are
welded to the car move at the same rate
in tandem and are not pushed back
well i hope he figured this out all by
himself yeah we we understand that uh
you know anything which uh is not tied
to the car moves back and he repeats
that he says everything which is on or
in the car and not physically part of
the car will not move with the car in
tandem yeah so far he hasn't explained
why what caused all these things not to
move with the car okay it's all he did
he's just
telling us this he's not giving us an
explanation then he says the air is
staying where it is and is not forced
backwards again he hasn't told us why he
just he's just making a statement saying
it does
okay the question is why is it not
forced back right and he hasn't
understood the question yet but he wants
the nobel prize for his great input okay
the vehicle is forced forwards and is
the cause of this he hasn't explained
the cause he just says the vehicle goes
forward and why does the air move back
he hasn't explained why the rear either
moves back or stays back okay that's the
issue
and so so he says uh as this uh object
within or on is not affixed to the car
it does not collect the same
acceleration again he hasn't told us why
it does not collect the same
acceleration okay this is the issue he
hasn't explained anything and so yeah
uh these
poor folks they think they have an
answer and all they did give us a bunch
of descriptions tell us what we already
know that the air stays back or the air
moves back whichever one you want it
doesn't really matter in this case and
the question is why does it move back
why does it stay behind when the car
moves forward that's the question he
hasn't explained the cause well they're
explaining with an assumption that they
feel is unnecessary to point out like
they're saying obviously the air is
going to move back but they're not
saying okay but put your finger on it
and so let's clarify what the problem is
so that i think even a flat earther can
understand it okay so i'm going to go
isn't the question simply what is
inertia or what causes inertia exactly
that's it and and i'm going to show you
something that will i think make it very
very clear okay so here here it goes
okay please pay attention flat earthers
okay i'm gonna show you something here
we have a van okay
and you can see that it moves forward
and we have one atom or one molecule you
can say one molecule of air one atom of
oxygen it doesn't really matter we have
a single particle inside the van which
is not attached to anything in the van
it's just floating there okay
now you can see when the van passes the
tree
the tree doesn't go with a van
now isn't that a miracle
you know and you say well why doesn't
the tree move together with a van okay
and you might say well maybe there's two
reasons one is that the tree is not
inside the van
right and the other one is that the tree
is stuck to the ground
okay
in the case of the particle well it's uh
not tied to the van but it is inside the
van and it doesn't appear to be tied to
anything to the ground or anything
now in the case of the tree i think it's
very clear people would say what's stuck
to the ground well why doesn't the
air molecule or the atom there why
doesn't that move with a fan that's the
million dollar question
okay
and
just to make it even clearer because i
know the flat earthers have a lot of
problem understanding the question here
let's go a little more in more detail
okay
we're gonna build a van and we're gonna
build it on top of a tree okay is the
tree going through the van yeah the tree
is inside the van
by mistake they built the van on top of
the tree okay with a hole in the with a
hole in the ground the tree is not tied
to anything in the van okay the tree is
just
sitting there without touching anything
in the van it's just like the molecule
there okay
so the tree is inside the van so now we
have both the molecule and the tree
inside the van the only difference is
apparently the tree is stuck to the
ground whereas the molecule is not the
molecule is floating okay
that's the situation okay now it turns
out that the ban moves forward okay
well we say well why did the tree stay
back well again people say well it's
inside the van yes but it's stuck to the
ground why did the particle
stay back that's the million-dollar
question
i mean is the particle also stuck to the
ground like the tree is stuck to the
ground do we understand the question
okay
so i hope you see the difference okay
here we have
the tree is inside the van but it's
stuck to the ground the particle is
inside the van but it's not stuck to the
ground okay do we understand that and
now we're gonna see how the van moves
forward the street the tree stays behind
despite that it's inside the van because
it's stuck to the floor to the ground
but the molecule also stays behind
despite the fact that apparently it's
not stuck to the floor the question is
why did the particle stay behind what
physical object compelled it to stay
behind like the tree and then gravity
well
we can't say gravity because that's a
concept we need a physical object guys i
need some physical object just
the ground is the physical object that
prevents a tree from moving okay
don't get ahead of yourself
that's not a that is answering anything
no i don't
because you're too smart you're not a
flat earther so you're not allowed
it's like a ball in a ball pit okay so
what is the solution well uh my good old
son he spilled the beans already yeah
it's the roast the ropes are holding on
to the atom that's why it stays behind
okay so there it is
the way it started and when the van
accelerates where does it what happened
to the molecule it stayed behind because
it's tied to every atom on earth that's
why there's a little bit of movement of
that atom but not so much that it goes
at the same speed as the van
okay we got that
so that's our solution to that the flat
earthers have to come up with us with
some kind of solution okay and of course
they can't use the word density they
can't use the word
mass they can't use the word charge they
can't use a cons or gravity they need a
physical object i put a physical object
i'm saying that atom is tied to every
atom on earth i mean you're basically
asking what is the physical mechanism
for gravity exactly and for uh inertia
et cetera in this case is the same yeah
yeah exactly and so the issue is i need
to know what held
that atom back in lieu of ropes what
else could it be you got that what is
what if not the ropes what is gravity
what is holding it there you get to say
gravity but what does that mean let's
just affect your playing down what okay
so now what happens people say bill
you're crazy what do you mean what do
you mean there's all these ropes holding
onto the atom where did you get this
nonsense
okay don't don't listen to me don't
believe in me
don't listen to me or believe in me
anymore i'm gonna show you
professor richard mueller from berkeley
university he's going to tell you okay
you brought this dude up a lot yeah we
got to bring them again because people
are not listening so i want you to
listen to professor richard miller he's
not a fan of the rope model okay but
he's gonna tell it to you like it is
okay give me a second here i'm gonna
answer black magic is what they said
yeah and here here we go okay you listen
to mr richard muller here he goes
what's the force of gravity on me um
it's the pull of the earth
on my body
so for example if you have the earth
with its big mass here and you have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
on the other hand a lot of atoms here
you're pulling on you're pulling on all
of them amazing thing about gravity is
it goes right through things
i hope you all listen to mr mueller
okay professor muller is saying to
follow me here i'm going to summarize
what he said in one picture okay so for
example if you have earth there's a big
mass here that's that earth there and
you have you with your little mass here
that's you sitting on top of the earth
on the big mass
every atom on the earth is pulling on
every atom of you you're also pulling on
it
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through
things okay does he have a nobel prize
though
is he worth listening to
so the issue is the following
yes every atom in your body is being
pulled by every atom on earth
please explain how that is possible if
you're not connected to any atom on
earth because you can't see or touch the
mediator that connects you to every atom
on earth well they're obviously throwing
gravitons at us
yeah
the negative force balls
you throw a negative ball at something
and it goes forward yeah negative
momentum negative momentum
and and yeah so
i'm saying that that atom right that
molecule of air is being held there
by ropes
an object that rests will stay at rest
and object emotion will stay in motion
unless acted on
by a net external force yeah
yeah
that's not a force there's no such
physical object called force so you
gotta draw the
physical object that causes that comes
in contact with a molecule don't tell me
don't repeat uh newton's uh laws or
whatever because those have nothing to
do with physics okay we need a physical
object guys we need uh for you to
identify the invisible intangible
physical object that keeps the atom the
molecule of air
in place when the car accelerates i
think you said it best earlier when you
said uh if all atoms of the earth are
pulling on us how could they do that if
not with ropes that that it's still a
question there remains to be answered if
not
if if we're not satisfied with with
gravitons i guess with negative because
those are the only two answers yeah
particles particles or some connection
some
elongating connection let's apply
mr uh professor mueller's
uh what he just said to
our situation here the one in the van
okay so let's look at it here he says he
says every atom on the earth is pulling
on every atom of you you're also pulling
on it the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things i
think it was history
yeah almost right so there it is every
atom on earth is pulling on every atom
of you and so there you have you that's
that little atom there and every atom on
earth is tugging on you it's keeping you
in place when the van accelerates it's
just like the tree you are being held in
place more or less there's a little bit
of movement obviously but the air
molecule cannot speed up as much as the
van because it's being held in place and
it's not tied to anything in the van
okay so that's
our solution you don't like the solution
no problem tell me what's in contact
with
the molecule and what i mean by that
when i say tell me don't give me words
like force and mass and none of the
nonsense of mathematics
you need to draw the physical object
draw a picture we want pictures we want
images we want to know what physical
object is in contact with a molecule we
really just have to be able to imagine
the
microscopic or
you know whatever is going on there how
do we imagine it without just throwing
words at it
like forget yeah but this is this is it
if you can see the movie in your head
without word forget explaining it to
someone else to see the movie in your
head what is holding that particle there
or that molecule
yeah
very important something's obviously
keeping it there in fact uh there's a
reason why it goes back one of these
the same fellow i think it was that i
showed before he says the following you
can see
how he ends his so-called reasoning okay
he goes through several things but look
at his last statement okay he says less
than stuff rises well he hasn't
explained anything
until they are unable to be supported by
the surrounding medium and fall back to
earth again
just a description no explanation of
what causes helium will swim through the
air upward the reason is density density
is not a reason density is a concept you
can't say density does this density does
that you got to put the physical object
and the reason for this is there is no
such uh place where there is nothing or
where nothing exists again
these are just statements okay but look
at the last one it says you are always
displacing something physically with
another physical object and so once
again i ask what is uh oh sorry wrong
one
what is let me get it here uh
what is causing here
uh
what is com in contact with the with a
molecule if he says a physical object
has to do it tell me what physical
object is in contact with a molecule in
the case of the tree we see why the tree
is is left behind because we say well
it's the ground the ground is preventing
the the tree from moving okay so that's
the physical object that's preventing
the tree from moving what's preventing
the molecule from moving okay what's
holding on to the molecule that's the
issue and so yeah this is this is the
problem the problem that nobody wants to
answer everybody just gives me
statements and say says well the the
molecule stays behind yeah we know it
stays behind don't tell me that again
why should it move though yeah well i
mean why not i mean the
seat moved and you say well it's stuck
to the to the car so what why didn't the
molecule move i mean even if it's not
stuck to the car and if it stayed behind
what held it there so whichever way you
go you got to tell me
what is holding on to it or what's
preventing it from moving forward
something is holding it back or or it
moves back if you if that's your theory
but whichever the case something comes
in contact with a molecule
and you got to tell me what that thing
is you got to identify you got to draw
it for me you got to show me somewhere
on the internet well i think you're
asking the question weirdly okay because
this is not so much something came in
contact with it is right now the force
that that
it doesn't go forward because nothing's
pushing it forward right but it's still
being held in place so there is a force
on it which is gravity we're not going
to
explain what gravity is yet yeah like
assuming i wanted to answer this
question right everyone understands that
the reason why the molecule isn't going
up
is because of gravity and the reason why
it isn't going further down is because
it's resting on other molecules
or whatever yeah well to put it in more
specific terms it's resting on it's like
a ball pit
resting on a bunch of balls of air yeah
the reason it doesn't go up is because
of gravity so we got two forces it's not
going or one force gravity is pulling it
down but it doesn't go further because
of all the balls good but that's
distance but that's what's only but we
still have that question of what is
gravity but then the question why does
it go forward also because what
you're saying
what what's holding it there and and and
you're saying gravity but then what is
gravity yeah that's the question yeah i
mean i gotta tell you what gravity is
that's where we're headed but you're
you're muddying the question with all
these extra words basically the question
that in
in that situation becomes what is
gravity yeah the problem is i don't want
to use the word gravity because it's a
concept and people will start talking
about concepts and forces
and i don't want them using any of those
words anyway yeah but
i'm going to stop it i'm going to if you
put the word gravity density mass
any of those in there i'm going to
cancel that i'm going to scratch it out
you need to put a physical object i need
a physical object that touches the
molecule that's what i want you to show
and and don't tell me it's air because
we're going to get rid of all the air we
have a single air molecule in there
does it stay there or does it move
forward it goes to the ground
well does it
yeah
well yeah but it's going to drop slowly
right now at the speed of gravity
exactly so so it's going to fall down
right let's assume
we could have vacuum there right yeah so
9.81 so well let's say the car
accelerates faster than that
it's going to fall like a ball and hit
the back of the vehicle yeah but the
question is again why does it fall
downwards what's holding it in place
because
why is it pulling or
holding it in place in this case is only
because it's in a ball pit well it's
like like mr uh mueller said every atom
on earth is connected to that atom in
fact let's let's let's pulling on it
let's change this around if the car were
in space
would the balls still
shoot to the back well it depends on how
far in space you are because i mean
because i think if you have gravity all
uh you know you have gravity up to a
certain point yeah but assuming you're
in the middle of nowhere basically okay
so
yeah between two gravities it's
negligible i think everest
is is correct saying uh an object that
isn't moved stays not moving i mean with
respect to what becomes a muddier
question but still if that car or you
know rocket ship now would go forward
all the balls all the air molecules
would go to the back
just because there's nothing that has
pushed them yet
so in that sense it's a confusing
question well it's uh another confusing
question in this sense uh the the tree
you know was not stuck to anything
except the ground okay so it's not stuck
to anything inside the car that's what
i'm saying okay the tree is completely
uh on its own right the car was built
around it okay it's only stuck to the
ground uh the tree is
and the car moves forward and we have no
problem with that we say well it's
because it's stuck to the ground the
ground prevented the tree from moving
okay that's the object that prevents the
tree from moving
and so the question is now you're saying
there's a bunch of marbles okay because
in this case we're talking about air
they're all moving around more or less
right but we're talking about we're
trying to isolate one molecule there and
we say why did that molecule
not move forward together with because
again you know you have all these
molecules there right
you could say that the car pushes all
these molecules forward okay why didn't
that happen if if the molecule is just
sitting on a pile of
if one marble is sitting on a pile of
marbles right and the car moves forward
all the molecules will move all the
marbles will move forward not yet well
yeah because you're moving the whole
pile of uh you're moving all the
molecules in the car remember
but it goes step by step at first they
don't go with it until it hits the back
no no because they're all kind of solid
they're touching each other yeah so so
the car is full of marbles you're gonna
have a wave of marbles hit the bag no no
because the whole car is full oh it's
just completely completely compressed so
as soon as the car moves all the m all
the marbles should move right every
single one of them should move forward
because there's no leeway right but this
is not the case these marbles
are special marbles they just stay in
place while the car moves forward and
you say why did the
molecules in the back push all of them
forward you know if the whole car is
filled with all these molecules it takes
a while
there's a lag there yeah but i mean can
we push molecules of air yeah
yeah we can we can move air all the way
around if the windows are open i mean if
you don't if you don't believe me
blow a balloon blow all the air in the
balloon move the balloon hopefully
neither the air goes through the balloon
all of it moves together with it right
it depends on how dense it is so the
question is
why did that little molecule stay in
place okay and again you got to draw the
physical object that holds it in place
that's that's the bottom line
okay let's move forward uh
i just wanted to show here with this uh
this illustration here you have a cowboy
pulling on a donkey we all understand
why the donkey moves towards the cowboy
very easily but what so we say well he
pulled on a rope and that's why the
donkey came forward kindergarten stuff
anybody can see it and explain to
anybody else the 10 year old kid now
we're gonna remove the rope okay here it
is so now we have this cowboy and he's
just
doing some fancy movement we need a
physicist and and now this this donkey
is moving forward
if you don't put something between the
hands of the cowboy and the donkey you
are doing this you're explaining this
with black magic what about uh gravitons
yeah well yeah but if you're scrolling
graviton yeah yeah but then you gotta
explain how the shooting outwards pulls
inwards but this is the question if you
put any concept in here you say it's
density if you say it's gravity you say
it's forced you say it's mass you
haven't answered the question the you
need to put the physical object that is
pulling on the donkey
here it's very straightforward you say
okay it was a rope you know that's the
cause that's the that's what's uh
pulling on the donkey and we all
understand it because the rope is a
physical object but here you know we
can't see the object and suddenly it
looks like black magic and so we say
what's going on here he's using the
force yeah and you can't say it was
force you can't say it was mass you
can't say it was gravity you gotta draw
the physical object that's in contact
with uh both the um
the um cowboy and the donkey the
midichlorians yeah okay
so again this has to do with physical
objects uh and that's going to be the
subject today
you can't do physics without an object
you need a physical object you have to
identify the physical object and again
there's a physical object that's pulling
on that atom inside the car and you have
to identify what that physical object is
which is invisible and intangible i'm
sorry an object is not that which you
can see or touch
so
don't talk about touch don't talk about
seeing don't talk about going to the lab
and running an experiment you can't see
or touch the electromagnetic ropes that
are in contact with the object what did
mr muller say he said that the funny
thing about gravity is it goes right
through things
you make it sound like he's like his
gospel or something yeah it is gospel
the cherry picked that one
okay and just for all you uh flat
earthers out there yes water does
curve we curve water very easily
under the rope model okay and so the
foul says the impossibility of proving a
physical horizon for example a human
observer at sea
level six kilometers away is clearly in
the realm of the observable see again
these people talk about observable of
running experiments and that has nothing
to do with science and that's the
problem with all this no physics is not
about experiments or
physics is not about proof which means
believing and convincing people
uh flat earthers are a little more
intelligent or smarter than
mathematicians why because they believe
in the flat universe but they still fall
short because they rely on experiments
whereas you're trying to do pure physics
which is purely logic based correct and
that's one issue but the other one is
that the mathematicians you know the
mathematical physicists they studied 10
years at the university to come out with
nonsense such as space-time and black
holes and big bangs
in that sense i give more credit to the
flat earthers they studied ten years in
the university so that they can pass it
on to the next day to study ten years in
the university that's all it is
and yes water does curve around the
earth and then you see why because you
have air and you have a water around the
earth and every atom of the earth is
pulling on every atom of air and on
every atom of water and where does it
pull it towards it pulls it towards the
center of the earth that's why that's
why the earth is spherical and that's
why the uh
water curves around the earth and that's
why air curves around the earth and flat
earthers have a problem with that
because they want to run an experiment
and they say well when i put water in my
glass i see a level surface
yeah
in your bathtub yeah no problem but see
their world is so tiny so we need to
really get them out there in space and
show them the big world
we have to find out why the moon doesn't
fly out of the solar system that's the
kind of weird thinking like if you just
have like assuming you could just have
an orb floating here it's weird thinking
things would like pull up it's weird
thinking that there's no such thing as
up basically
in space there's no such thing as up
yeah that's true there's no up
in space it's just all relative up up is
a qui uh an issue something we invented
here on earth yeah because everything
goes
down but that doesn't exist it's so
weird to think
yeah okay uh we also had a mooney and
the moonies are very close to the flat
earthers sometimes uh moonies are people
who don't think that we went to the moon
okay that we stepped on the moon and
fell says he's a little upset at me and
says i've given you two huge problems
almost space
uh about space one is the o-rings in the
iss outgassing haven't been changed in
20 years and the second one is the moon
camera cannot have taken those pictures
on the moon i'm giving you solid physics
the film uh
emotion i guess emotion he was saying
would have been boiled off in the vacuum
of space
okay and so let's uh look at the
o-ring issue first okay here it is uh
this is what i found out there two two
uh articles one says the inner shaft
relies on a system of special grooves
that compress the o-rings with more
uh
these are o-rings they're made out of
special material especially for space
stuff on the other and what they do they
create this isolation okay and the
isolation would have prevented prevents
from no no this guy says should we
replace the o-rings and so
these are two articles the one on the
bottom uh right is from the company that
makes the o-rings for nasa for space uh
exploration and so the one on the top
says rings with more or less pressure as
the windows open and close when pressure
is applied the o-ring will move toward
the low pressure side of the groove
filling any holes that might be
dangerous at its core this is the same
concept used to seal a dslr camera in an
underwater housing what does the company
that makes the o-ring say says every
o-ring chosen for aerospace applications
must be able to withstand incredible
stress and extreme temperatures straight
quality specifications have been placed
on o-ring manufacturers including the
as9100
certification
okay so the issue here of course they
would say that they may well yeah but
the point is okay yeah i mean i haven't
gone inside the company to uh prove any
of this all i'm saying
uh the companies and other people have
different opinions and this individual
and they say look these o-rings are very
special and whether they're replaced
quite often or not i have no idea where
this all
proved to himself that they haven't
changed the o-rings a hundred years and
all this stuff where i don't know and i
don't even know if he knows what an
o-ring is his spelling obviously doesn't
show much uh education so how much are
they paying you to say this
uh company gives me all these kickbacks
[Music]
here's the second issue the issue is
uh
was addressed sometime back i think it
was the same file who asked the question
he says the film used for photographs
and for the films of the apollo missions
worked in the ultra vacuum of 10 to
minus 12 minus tour year
minus 12 a tour
and so this is the answer i found on the
internet some time back so i did answer
his question
and i said this is what the article said
the film itself was normal photographic
film although a special emotion made
specifically for nasa it wasn't some
super exotic photographic film printed
on an unobtainium
bass it was standard acetate film with
gelatin emulsion and then another i
think it was the same fellow or someone
else said is it possible to use the
camera in low pressure or vacuum and
this was the answer i found or this is
not mine this is from someone else the
camera itself can work in vacuum a few
issues have to be addressed internal
temperature sensors should be monitored
some electronic components may be
overheated because there is no
convective cooling outgassing of the
glue and lubrication may occur depending
on estimated operating time in vacuum
modification of the camera must be
considered instead of modifying the
camera environment enclosure can be used
okay so they have looked at this problem
they realized the problem they found
fixes to it technical fixes
apparently okay so this fellow simply
needs to come up to speed do his own
research i haven't looked into this any
more than that because i don't think
it's worth looking into it i think they
can take photographs in space okay under
different conditions they just they are
aware of the problems of just using
regular cameras out there so they take a
different type of picture at least in 69
today they probably do it all
electronically anyways okay
okay and so let's move on to the issue
of existence now
what is existence and a fellow asked a
question he says is there an episode
called what is existence from two months
ago
and the answer is yes yeah there is an
episode but i had to re um
uh you know uh cover some points uh uh
cross some t's dot some eyes you know
and also summarize a little bit of why
existence is important okay have you
said that a million times why existence
is important well i'm gonna say it a
hundred more times because uh people
don't seem to listen okay and so i do
like to rub it in
first of all uh and this is the the
rundown okay there's no rational
definition of the word science the word
physics or the word philosophy today
anywhere on the planet okay so we had to
define the word science for the first
time uh at the beginning of this century
or latin end of last century okay
rational explanations that's the new
definition of science anything that came
before it is not science okay so
whatever newton did whatever they did in
the 17th century all the way to the end
of the 20th century none of that was
science because science was never
defined properly to this day the
establishment does not have a valid
irrational definition of science by
rational i mean one that can be used
consistently rationally okay
physics is a branch of science and
therefore it's uh first of all it's the
science of existence okay
uh physics deals only with that which
exists
and uh since we don't have a definition
of exist in the last three thousand
years we had to define the word exist as
well
what is exist an object that has
location it has to be an object concepts
cannot be said to exist not in science
not in physics love cannot be said to
exist not in science intelligence cannot
be said to exist concepts do not exist
that means that energy doesn't exist
force doesn't exist mass doesn't exist
charge doesn't exist wave none of the
concepts of mathematics uh exist can be
said to exist because they're
unimaginable only objects can be said to
exist in physics because they're
imaginable
not only imagine but uh even before we
imagine them they have shape on their
own i mean if we're talking about
existing objects we're talking about
objects that exist before we ever
existed well no but the point is if you
want to explain something rational
explanations it has to be imaginable
that is yeah yeah yeah yeah of course
and for that uh well the way you prove
imagination is by drawing so uh you
point to something and you say look
let's assume that's a table you know and
you point to a table and people know
what the word table refers to it refers
to that object that has shape in front
of you and and so on that's the way you
present an object in in physics and at
that moment in time it's the only object
in the universe it had better be if it's
got something else in there like
someone's gonna say later on shadow no a
shadow is not a standalone object i
can't point to a shadow all by itself a
shadow is
something that requires something else
okay so
shadow is is not a stand-alone object i
got a problem with your definition of
science of existence in physics because
often we use imagine imagination to
explain stuff
thought experiments yeah and which
aren't things that actually exist well
what i'm saying is uh with the the
purpose of the
um of the uh of this uh what is it of
the
uh experiment the thought experiment is
to mimic the real world that's hopefully
the the purpose it i mean if it's got to
do with fizzy otherwise you know you can
talk about stuff that you know yeah but
real world be becomes an issue of
observers again
uh no no no no because we're not talking
about observing we're saying we're
trying to explain we're focusing on the
expertise yeah one thing at a time if
you're imagining a scenario yeah to
mimic the real world if you're not
mimicking the real world no holds barred
then we're talking about things that
don't exist it's all thought experiment
and it's got nothing to do with physics
important which is the weird part
because if we're doing it to mimic the
real world how do we know what mimics
the real world if we're not observing we
don't know because knowledge has nothing
to do with science we explain so that
someone understands what we're trying to
do and that's what we use the thought
experiment for we use it as an example
saying look i'm giving you an example of
how i think the universe works for that
you draw on
some object and you say this is the
mechanism that i think that underlies
this phenomenon but that mimic the real
world part
there's there's there's a problem in
there well no the the issue is that it's
uh you're saying that it's all abstract
but the issue is um i'm gonna draw
something because i'm gonna talk about a
mechanism or whatever i explain is
related to some kind of object in which
i'm going to put it in some kind of
motion to explain the mechanism so it
doesn't matter if you believe in it or
if it's real out there i'm going to
explain the mechanism to you alone
that's all so that you understand it
what exactly exists out there
whatever you believe well you can
believe in god that's what i'm saying if
we're going to be dealing with
assumptions anyway then there's no point
in invoking the word exist
like science of existence it's more like
no no but
this is the context the context is that
you say let us assume x exists
and so you make an assumption so that
you bring it into your presentation your
dissertation you say we're going to make
an assumption i want you to concede my
assumption that the tree exists or the
table exists so that now based on that
assumption i'm going to explain a
mechanism to you so that you understand
it now that you understood it we're done
with science now it continues is
religion do you believe in it that's a
separate issue do you accept the
assumption that's again a question of
belief the question is did you
understand the theory the mechanism that
i just explained based on that
assumption that's the issue okay so
anyways uh
continuing here with this i'm saying
that physics requires an object okay but
it turns out that nobody has defined
what an object is in the last three
thousand years oh they have but
that's an irrational definition and
therefore it's satisfied beyond their
rational it's uh circular it's circular
yeah and they never get to the heat of
it but that's why we call it irrational
because if it's a circular definition
it's an irrational definition
the only uh
property
all objects have the universal property
of all objects is
uh shape every object has shape you
cannot even imagine an object that does
not have shape okay on the other hand uh
the current one which is c touch the
notion that they have of object c touch
that is an irrational definition first
because you're relying on a verb uh c
and touch our verbs that means you're
also relying on observers okay you're
saying you need to see
uh the object and that not all objects
can be seen and certainly not an object
on the other side of the universe you
can't see not i can do one better okay
it's it's also circular because they're
saying what is an object that which i
can see and touch yeah what can i see
and touch objects
yeah but there's no there's no
you know and who are you you're an
object already to do the seeing and the
touchy yes what these people are saying
is that an asteroid and the moon are not
objects until one hits the other
only then when they touch well no no
they're coming out they're saying it's
touchable essentially yeah
but why is it touchable because it's an
object well yeah
you're just saying it's not you're just
defined object with objects yeah but uh
see i don't know if the table on the
other side of the universe i want to
cling on
i don't know if i can touch it but
that's where they invoke the circular
reasoning because they say well i can't
touch it to prove it but it is touchable
assuming it's touchable okay how do you
know it's touchable well it's an object
well
yeah but listen listen to something else
uh there's the moon we all see it right
but the blind man doesn't so he can't
see it for him it's not an object i
can't see it you know i can't see the
moon so we're going to exclude all blind
people saying well all blind people you
don't know what an object is you know i
mean what are we going to do here so no
it's an irrational definition and
because uh the c-touch definition that
we've used for all these years is an
irrational definition then we've never
defined the word existence and because
we never defined the word existence we
never defined the word physics which is
the science of existence well that's the
self-collecting part as far as i'm
concerned the the what stamp collecting
part yeah what is what is physics and i
don't really care yeah as long as we
answer the questions who cares what
branch it falls under i still think that
well yeah that part is sam collecting
that's true okay anyways uh so here we
have uh the issue of black hole does the
black hole exist does the is the black
hole an object does it belong to physics
you know so the question so those are
the questions and before we can say that
a black hole exists we have to define
the word exist and we're saying it's an
object that has location okay
and not that which we could see or touch
which in this case it turns out we can't
even see or touch a black hole either
one so the question is even under the
current definition that the
establishment has
you know the black hole doesn't qualify
as an object but certainly not under our
definition which is shape we have no
shape there and why because what we're
talking about is zero dimensionality
we're saying that a black hole is zero
dimensional no size no matter whatsoever
and it turns out that you know here you
have a couple of professors university
professors physics professors or
mathematical physics professors
both of whom say that
matter inside a black hole is crushed
out of existence well then hold on it
then under under these assumptions would
it be correct to say the black hole
doesn't exist but does do things in our
universe
well that doesn't exist but
i'm getting to that you know in a sense
we have an irrationality because we have
to determine whether a black hole
belongs to physics to begin with and i'm
saying it doesn't because it's not an
object and if it does it's not an object
it doesn't exist and if it doesn't exist
not even part of physics but that's
that's my reason they circumvented that
they said it doesn't exist but it does
exert some event
it's worse than that they say it does
exist oh then they're looking for it now
they're cheating now they're cheating
and so here we have uh i just want to
reinforce that by saying that
the
here we have two professors at least
you'll find more out there that say look
that the black hole crushes all matter
out of existence but it turns out that
mass is the quantity of matter or a
measure of a quantity of matter if
matter is crushed out of existence we
have no mass
okay and if we have no mass how is it
that a black hole has infinite mass or
lots of mass if there's no matter in it
and matter and mass is a measure of the
quantity of matter
so it's like you know we crush the
elephant out of all its structure all
its architecture there's nothing there
but it turns out that
the two tons are still in there but
there's no elephant
that's what they're telling you okay
now a lot of people have questioned me
uh and they say bill where did you get
the idea that
one that all matters crushed out of
existence and the other one that a black
hole is zero dimensional a lot of people
have problems with that they say bill
you invented that stuff
let's take care of that part make sure
that all those people who are ignorant
people we enlighten them today okay
and for that i'm going to use authority
because they believe in authority that's
where they got all this stuff to begin
with and we're going to bring into the
picture
uh two professors one of them a very
famous one his name is stephen hawking
who died a couple years ago okay and
this is what mr hawking says in his book
please listen carefully you're not
listening to bill gatey now you're
listening to stephen hawking you know
he's got a waffle prize uh go a wolf
medal i don't have i don't even have a a
chocolate medal this is a real physicist
now yeah we're kind of a real physique
so here he goes okay he says
chandrasekhar calculated that a cold
star of more than about one and a half
times the mass of the sun would not be
able to support itself against its own
gravity would it collapse to infinite
density infinite density means no volume
eddington was shocked by that
implication and he refused to believe
chandrasekhar's result eddie thought it
was simply not possible that a star
could collapse to what to a point
einstein himself wrote a paper in which
he claimed that stars would not shrink
two what
zero
size
zero size however he was awarded meaning
chandrasekhar right he was awarded the
nobel prize in 1983 for his early work
on the limiting mass of cold stars
chandrasekhar had shown that the
exclusion principle could not halt the
collapse of a star more massive than the
chandrasekhar limit
and here we have a professor from
cambridge university before you go on to
that yeah so so what he's saying is
despite eddington and einstein's uh
what do you what do you call it uh uh
misgivings chandrasekhar still said it
does crush things out of existence yeah
and they agreed that that's what he was
saying that's important because here you
have uh eddington and einstein and they
both understood what chandrasekhar was
saying which is it collapses to zero
size a black hole is zero size there's
nothing that will stop it from
collapsing to nothing to to empty space
to vacuum that's what they're saying but
then doesn't that mean it depends on who
you ask because according to eddington
and einstein it doesn't go to zero size
yeah but but
but they understood right they
understood that that's what
chandrasekhar was saying that's the
important part and now here we have
another professor okay he wrote a book
and this was published by cambridge
university i mean does cambridge just
publish any nonsense from any dissident
out there
absolutely not he says on solving the
equation with a particular value row of
central density you will get a model of
a star with mass m and radius r
plot r as a function of m and show that
r
falls to zero
falls to zero when m is equal to the
chandrasekhar mass if you can do all
these then you have repeated the
calculation for which chandrasekhar won
the nobel prize so when the mass reaches
a certain point
it continues until uh there's zero
volume and infinite mass that's what
these people are saying so yes a black
hole is zero dimensional no size no
volume anyone who says anything
different than that is an ignoramus okay
you heard it here first okay so please
don't tell me that
that it's infinitesimal no such monster
it goes to zero nothing i like infinite
testimony that's like no we didn't hit
zero yet because yeah
because what it is what they use is as x
approaches zero that's you know what
they're using calculus okay and uh and
and so it approaches but see approaching
the station is not being at the station
and what they're saying is it is that
approaching the station whenever they
need the approaching to the station they
use the infinitesimal word and when they
say at the station they use zero and so
they equate infinitesimal with zero
that's the it's a
it's a um wizardry that's all it is
okay so yeah let's make sure that we
understand black hole is zero
dimensional if it's zero dimensional
it's not an object if it's not an object
it cannot exist if it cannot exist it's
not part of physics or of science we're
done period end of story but according
to them it doesn't exist but it does do
stuff
yeah it both starts around it's a
happening with no location well yeah so
here we have it okay we have if god
wants to exist well he's got to be an
object and he's got to have location
it's not enough for god to be an object
a thing like a human uh with a magic
wand or whatever is that's not enough
because you could be dreaming god but if
god has distance between my chest and
him and his chest then god exists by
definition not because i believe or
disbelief okay so that's the definition
of exist
and uh under that definition we can't
say that a black hole exists because a
black hole is not an object but it's not
an object doesn't it just saying love
doesn't exist love doesn't exist i'm
sorry not in physics in ordinary speech
love exists intelligence exists data
exists that energy exists not in physics
in physics it's got to be a physical
object if it wants to exist to begin
with and that's not enough it's got to
have location is that is that why
philosophers also get tangled up with
the consciousness because it doesn't
really exist it's like happening
unconscious
consciousness mind thought
synonyms whatever you call it mine yeah
all those words are synonyms does that
have a location and there's no location
what you have is it's a process you can
say the brain has location you can say
the cells that create this thought this
process has location the thought doesn't
matter but thought itself what's the
location of thought if it's a process
it's like saying running
has location no the boy has location not
running you're saying fire doesn't exist
exactly fire is a process of combustion
and you know there's a process going on
so you can't say fire exists
what exists is the atom the uh for
example could be the carbon and it could
be the oxygen uh atom right that could
you can say exist but you cannot say
that the process of one burning of
oxidizing the other that that process
exists okay it's like a ball falling
doesn't exist but a ball does exactly
boy running is not a thing boy is uh is
a thing running is what he does you
can't say running existence right
that's the issue that makes
um
sense
trying to think of something or they
would kill that but it came off the dome
okay so let's get on with our um
uh science critic electricity doesn't
exist either exactly because it's a
process it's weird yeah okay anyways
here's the science critic and i'm going
to put him on for a second so that you
can hear what he has to say and he's
going to say that another existing thing
that we have out there he says that
virtual particles exist he believes that
there are such things as virtual
particles gravity doesn't exist either
exactly because it's
a concept this is getting weird yeah you
can say that the ropes exist that cause
gravity but not the gravity or density
density doesn't it
[Music]
but that's also why you harp so much on
not using the word density mass and all
these things because they don't really
exist those are those are those concepts
in the sense that there's no
there's no shape there there's no thing
that's bumping into another thing
there's placeholders
they're placeholders that people don't
realize are price hold they put them in
there and say oh the force did that what
do you mean to force it you mean the
horse the horse could have done it not
the force where's yoda when you need it
okay so this is the the um
this is our science critic
and he's going to say that
virtual particles exist and so the
question to you for you to think in the
next few minutes is
do virtual particles exist if you know
what they are otherwise we're going to
enlighten you on what they are so here
we go give me a second so i put this
follow on
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal
include are there such things as virtual
particles
virtual particles exist
now it sounds like what he's talking
about here are virtual particles and
virtual particles certainly explain
certain things like the kashmir effect
just because you cannot imagine virtual
particles doesn't mean that they do not
exist now maybe that virtual particles
don't actually exist and there is some
other explanation for the casimir effect
but you need to actually come up with
another explanation for the kesmir
effect saying i can't imagine virtual
particles doesn't cut it
okay
so the question the million dollar
question today is do virtual particles
exist
and for those of you who don't know what
a virtual particle is let's find a
definition okay so here we have the
definition we find out there virtual
particle exhibits some of the
characteristics of an ordinary particle
okay while having its existence
limited by the uncertainty principle
it's existence limited they're limiting
the existence of god can you believe
this okay
any object that exists for a limited
time that's what a virtual particle is
at limited time okay and then virtual
particles exist only
temporarily
you know sounds quite ad hoc to me if
you if you ask me right the lifetime of
real particles is typically vastly
longer than the lifetime of the virtual
particles no kidding if it's got a
limited existence yeah
and then they finished saying the
concept of virtual particles
was a particle
a thing an object or is it a concept
what do you mean a concept of virtual
particles well it's a it's a thing when
they need it to be yeah so so what do
they use virtual particles for
just one example i'll give you an
example i'll give you a couple examples
first let me give you the example of the
um
dark matter and the reason i need to put
that in there is that again is there
such a thing as dark matter is there a
physical object called dark matter out
there i ain't seen no dark matter in my
body
it's not so much that first they can't
see it or touch it so that would uh
under the
mathematical definition c touch that
would be excluded anyways
but they've how do they come up with
dark matter why is it that all
mathematicians believe in dark matter
why all the astronomers pointing their
telescopes out there trying to find it
looking for an invisible thing
where did they get this idea well the
idea came because there was an equation
and they needed to figure out why the
stars on the outside on the outskirts of
the galaxy were traveling faster than
the around the galaxy faster than those
on the inside and so they said the only
thing they could come up with the only
explanation was mass
they said well we only have one solution
that's mass what else could it be
and so they put started putting mass
they said well
we're putting it by finger you know
we're putting it by hand in there we're
putting all this mass sprinkling it on
the outside of the galaxy just to make
the equation come out right
and they call that ad hoc putting of
kilograms out there they call that dark
matter so it was put in by hand
and the same thing comes with the
virtual particle they have an equation
suddenly they accelerate a particle
along the beam line over there at cern
or slack or fermilab it doesn't do what
they calculated well they said you know
there's something else going on i need
some more charge i need some more mass i
need some more energy i need more
something in there to fill in the blank
because otherwise the equation doesn't
come out right
and so they said
why don't we borrow some energy some
charge some mass some whatever from this
thing
and put it in the equation they say hey
now the equation works no kidding and
they say yeah but then suddenly the
equation it's like it suddenly goes away
it goes it's only a fleeting moment
where they can measure that and then it
goes away and so they said well
we got a solution we'll call it a
virtual particle it comes in when we
need it ad hoc
and then when we don't need it goes back
to i don't know to never never land i
sound like bad mathematicians like they
got the calculation wrong and then
they're like oh well
whatever we got wrong this is if
anything you could say it reverse you
could say they're good mathematicians
lousy physicists because
they haven't explained
how this really works and that explains
why mr
feynman says no one understands any of
this but it seems like their
calculations are off too well their
calculations are off but they fix them
immediately they just put
you know a variable in there by hand and
they say well there it is that's the
solution we put more charge more energy
and in the case of dark matter they put
more mass and they fix the problem and
now they tell the astronomers go look
for it
i love that what moved the curtain god
now go look for them
yeah the angels yeah the angels
point your telescopes
okay so here here's uh
here's my analysis okay a virtual
particle it's just a quick rundown
virtual particle is not a particle
that's that's the issue
in qm a particle is not a particle
okay people think of particles some kind
of core possible you know a grain of
dust a grain of sand uh
you think of a little tiny
speck of dust of some kind that's what
you're thinking of that's what the
layman thinks every time he hears the
word particle
that's not what a particle is in quantum
mechanics let alone a virtual particle
okay so what is a particle well uh
there's three kinds you could say and
they're all related to sizes one is the
macro particle the one we all understand
by the word particle which is a speck of
dust you know grain of sand any of those
right that's a particle something you
can see touch you know macro we'll call
it a macro particle because you can see
or touch it you can relate to it
then you have the point
particle here we go and and this is a
little tricky okay
it has no size it's a concept because it
has no size it's there's no
volume no shape no nothing there and
they call that a virtu a particle a
point particle right that's a point
particle and it could be a gluon they
call it a point particle it could be an
electron they call it a point particle
they've never seen one they never
photographed one they never interviewed
one so they don't know what it looks
like they have no idea and they don't
care what it looks like they just give
it values they say so much charge so
much mass they give it all all these
mathematical values these properties but
they don't tell you what it looks like
and they say we don't know what it looks
like we've never seen one period we're
done and they call it a point particle
okay
and part of that has to do with the fact
that the point particle they say it's an
elementary particle like you see there
at the bottom meaning it's not made of
anything smaller
it's like the ultimate particle it's not
made of anything itself at least for now
until they smash it and for that they
would need a collider as big as the
solar system you know so
good luck with that one
and then you have the virtual particle
which is an ad hoc
particle which ain't a particle to begin
with particle is not a particle but here
we have a virtual non-particle
okay
and it appears at the whim of the
mathematician to make the equation come
out right
so you have all these different kinds of
particles you should be aware that when
they're using the word particle in
quantum mechanics they're not talking
about that first one the macro particle
a real thing they're talking about maybe
a vibration local vibration of a field
maybe they're talking about uh wave
particle duality
uh the corkscrew you know uh that
mr
roger penrose put in his book ridiculous
thing where he shows this corkscrew
that's supposed to represent both
notions the wave and the particle i mean
it's pretty close
yeah
of course that's about it we're getting
there good as it gets anyways the point
is um
you know this fellow believes in in
little ghosts in in uh
spirits he thinks that there are such
things as virtual particles because with
it they can explain the casimir effect
well we don't need the virtual particle
for that we always had spirits for that
you know angels of god we already had
all those things but now you're just
being facetious no no i'm not i'm being
realistic because uh traditional
religion probably had a better answer
than the virtual particle which is a
non-part non entity to begin with i mean
if you bring an angel you know i can
imagine an angel he's got wings you know
a little plate on his head i can say
well he did this well yeah okay
some people have played some have a yeah
i don't know uh but angels we can all
imagine but we cannot imagine a virtual
particle uh because it has no size no
shape it's just a value that they put in
an equation whenever they need it and it
flies away whenever they don't need it
so what is that it's it's just ad hoc
it's nonsense okay so yeah if i were to
choose i'll still stay with stick to
traditional religion and say that angels
explain it better than virtual particles
i actually agree with one of the
comments someone supposed to hear yusuf
yeah who was saying i hope you find
someone who would use your rope
hypothesis as a mental model at least
and apply the math to see if it stands
up
yeah okay uh the math is very easy
because it's not what it means equation
well yeah but like if if you could
measure or like do the math on on the
torsion or that double helix to see if
you could apply easy it's uh little c
lc the torsion on the rope is always see
it's a constant throughout the universe
or at least in our neighborhood i don't
know if at the edge of the universe it's
the same uh value but again uh that's up
for other people to figure out
the other issue is that you know as far
as gravity is concerned just use
newton's equation and explains at least
in our neighborhood again uh how uh how
that works perfectly well
again it doesn't work as well outside
of the solar system and i've explained
that with a pioneer anomaly okay but
that's a long story to do now you can
look up my
video pioneer anomaly and uh you'll get
an insight into that but the point here
is that yeah we do have equations for
the rope model and they're the equations
we've had for 400 years so here's
newton's gravitational equation and we
have the value of c uh for the tension
on the rope they fit too but one thing
i'm wondering is
assuming you used the
rope model or or a double helix kind of
thing and
could you with with the
calculation we already have of gravity
somehow figure out how many atoms there
are in the universe because if every
atom is connected to each other couldn't
you
i don't i'm sure there's some derivative
you could find off that i'll tell you
i'll tell you why you can't first of all
er we don't know how big the universe is
but then even worse we don't know how
many ropes are inside an atom but that's
what i'm saying isn't that calculable no
it's not because ropes super impose
so we're in the same boat as quantum
mechanics and people say how can two
rows be at the same place at the same
time or superimposed
first ask the question to quantum
mechanics don't ask me the question ask
them how can two particles be at the
same place at the same time at least we
don't see the nonsense that a particle
can be at two places at one yeah
it gets weird but we agree with quantum
that two ropes can be at the same place
at the exactly the same time they can
superimpose because ropes don't touch
each other
and people have trouble with that
because they're
immediately go to our macro world and
say well i can't do that with two ropes
in the lab of course you can't because
the ropes in the lab touch each other
they're made out of atoms the roast
mother nature uses they don't touch each
other they superimpose oh now we're
using magic we're using magic when we
need it all we had to do was clarify
that two ropes
can occupy the same place strain space
at the same time
one issue and the other one is robes
cannot touch each other we're done
that's with that assumption it's an
assumption it's an assumption
with that assumption we can explain the
rope uh you know all the you know the
phenomenal phenomenon
right
all we have to do is make that
assumption it's the same assumption
quantum mechanics makes
it's the same assumption
relativity makes uh implicitly okay so
please
before you hit me
go hit quantum okay don't come and say
bill how can that be possible ask the
least that's that's yeah that's one that
everyone assumes it's it's hard to avoid
that one it'd be nice if someone comes
up with the theory that that
satisfies that but
remains to be seen there's certain
things i mean
you have to concede one thing we cannot
see or touch
the
uh
the whatever is pulling on on this
pencil downwards which as mr muller said
uh
richard muller the professor at berkeley
right
every atom of this pencil is tied is
bound is being pulled by every atom on
earth so if it's being pulled we cannot
see or touch whatever is pulling on it
but okay it's not going through there
right it's going right through there
we're just touching the air but we're
not touching whatever's contact with in
contact with each atom of this pencil so
we can't see or touch
whatever's there so you cannot talk
about c touch and you cannot say well
two ropes cannot superimpose because
that's not logical that's not rational
it's not rational in our macro world uh
on the world that we are used to it's
we're talking about mother nature's
world where we cannot see or touch her
mediators in her world it's perfectly
natural for two ropes to superimpose
because they don't have the ability to
touch each other because the word touch
only comes into play
from the atom and higher level only at
the atomic level do we have the word
touch before that there is no touch okay
except there is one exception sorry uh
magnetism
but that's a long story okay i'm just
not gonna get into that okay let's get
over to some of the questions people
made i don't know if uh anyone has made
any questions there that are worth is
the rope electromagnetic
well electromagnetic is a is um
just a label okay
uh it comes from the 19th century you
know they invented the words magnetism
or magnet and electricity you know uh
electric you know they invented these
words and then mr um uh james maxwell
he came up with these equations four
equations for which he is famous and he
came up with the electromagnetic wave
he's saying there's an electric field
and a magnetic field both
running at 90 degrees to each other and
they conform or they comprise this
thingy this abstraction known as an
electromagnetic or transverse wave
what we did we took this transverse wave
which is again a um
a helical thing but in two dimensions
and we we are doing it in three
dimensions and you can see here the
shape okay this is a rope and it's a
three-dimensional
okay it's a three-dimensional
model
of what we say or the assumption we make
for what mother nature uses to do light
and gravity and we're saying
that the famous two-dimensional
electromagnetic wave is really a
three-dimensional
electric thread twined around a
three-dimensional magnetic thread and
they form the three-dimensional
rope
so thin so small
that it is three-dimensional but at a
level that you're talking about the
fine
uh what is it the fine constant um
i can't remember the full term but the
point the fine uh what is it
really really small yeah very thin
you're talking about something that we
cannot even relate to small doesn't even
do it justice exactly it's infinite
testimony yeah that is infinite
but it's bigger than zero right yeah
something like that let me get to some
of the questions again one of the follow
says you like that picture though yeah
because this is
this here is a brilliant question oh
okay brilliant question that i have
never seen anyone give a straight answer
to you pick up and drop your pen where
did your energy go which allowed you to
lift the pen
energy cannot be destroyed only
converted so where did your energy go
there are only a few options to consider
and he clarifies i have zero scientific
education but as a professional
as a professional i analyze data uh well
thanks for clarifying that you have no
education thank you for that but let me
answer uh his question uh where did the
energy go okay that's what he wants to
know
and here we have it okay uh this is
where the energy goes there's no such
thing as energy
never use the word energy efficient
science now you can use it in ordinary
speech and talk about your energy bill
if you want no problem but don't bring
it into science it has nothing to do
with science energy is one of those
magical words that mathematics has
invented because they have no answers to
how the universe works so
well aside from that energy is a
quantity that's all it is it's just a
number with a unit behind it so
whichever energy you invoke you're
talking about a number with a unit
that's all it is it's an abstraction
there is no physical standalone object
called energy that you can draw a
picture of okay
energy is a concept therefore right and
concepts don't go anywhere so don't tell
me where the energy went because
concepts never move the day they they
move it's because you had too much
uh havana club to drink okay so
don't get any shots of that against
spirits the spirits have got you
energy concepts cannot physically be
destroyed you cannot destroy energy or
create it because energy is a concept we
don't create
or destroy concepts destroy injustice
yeah
destroy the concept
energy uh reification of a concept
that's what the word energy is energy is
has everything to do with math nothing
at all to do with physics so please
never use the word energy in my presence
uh it tends to upset my stomach i mean
it's not also just math like you said
it's a in common languages used a lot
like oh man that's a lot of energy i'm
tired
it's how we have a notion of what we
mean but it can mean a lot of things
yeah
it's an overused word and it's an
overused words because it's like the
word spirit when you don't understand
something just say spirit and you fix
the problem it's a yeah it's a
placeholder it's a place where you say
oh the spirit did it and this is what we
use for things that like hold motion
essentially and the same thing with
energy you say i don't have enough
energy what did you mean by that uh you
don't have energy like you don't have
ten batteries low you don't have ten
dollars in your pocket is that how you
don't have energy that's what it feels
like
[Laughter]
okay the fellow says it's not the ropes
okay so what is it the phenomenon of
gravity is mediated by virtual
archimedes screws
and there you see what other kennedy's
screw is he's i guess he's got all these
things
uh creating gravity out there all these
uh
i think it's like a metal uh
twirling thing yeah maybe maybe gravity
is made out of some kind of metal
yeah it looks like a drill bit or
something of some kind and so he says
the phenomenon of gravity is mediated by
archimedes screws trillions of electric
ether perturbations
ether perturbations what is ether
i mean uh he hasn't told us what ether
is and how the ether
relates to this physical object which
looks like a metal screw
what do you think no no the ether are
those little red balls oh is that what
they are those are ethers or i thought
it was the the screw itself there are
trillions of electron ether
perturbations is anything about the
balls i i don't know i think he's
talking about the gravity as well i mean
it's got to be the the blades
because without the blades those little
balls wouldn't move but
trillions of electric ether
perturbations is in a sentence
that's just so i don't know which one he
i think he's referring to the blades
because without the blades you don't
have the
you know virtual screws what's a virtual
screw
virtual particle but isn't virtual just
like computers
yeah i mean they just invent words and
they think they answer the question
so i'm just going to relate to one word
and that's the word ether unless we know
what he's referring to when he says
ether we have a problem here and again
usually it's all these electric universe
uh
individuals and they use the word ether
and they use the word electricity and
they never define any of these okay so
here's the here's ether for you okay
this is what ether is okay a bunch of
particles gazillions of particles that's
what the ether is
if you disagree that this is the ether i
need a picture of the ether i need a
snapshot a drawing uh some kind of image
of the ether
i don't want a definition because if you
define the word ether you do then ether
is not a physical object see we do not
define chairs and we do not define trees
and we do not define rocks not in
physics we point to them and i want you
to point to ether if you're going to use
it as a physical object okay if you're
going to say it's a a kimity screw or
whatever nonsense
point to it i need to know what ether is
before you put it in motion i mean i
could have pointed to it but we threw
out our broken tv
yeah more or less that's what it was a
broken tv had all these little dots
that's the that's the ether okay if you
don't agree
point give me a picture i need a picture
of these or a snapshot a drawing
an image a painting
um
a statue
mock-up whatever i need something
physical don't begin defining what the
ether is because if you define it if you
can define the ether for sure it's not
an object objects we point to
concepts we define
if you define it it's a concept if it's
a concept you can't use it as an object
we got that okay those are basic things
of
kindergarten physics okay so if you
don't have that much up there well what
can i say
okay uh already good question yeah we
can answer it towards the end again okay
we'll ask a question we'll continue
yeah go ahead what's the question we got
here which is um
so objects that are that which have
shape and shape isn't what you see in
touch correct why would i guess a better
i would address that in fact okay well a
better way to phrase that is something
like
can something have shape i.e an air
molecule even though it is invisible
okay
yeah it's a question i had on the list
so
if you wait a second we'll get there uh
here's another issue fellow says what is
causing atoms to expand and contract to
torque the rope
okay
and uh so there you see it uh this is my
version of it it's that every atom in
the universe is tugging i'm going to use
that word tugging it's not really
tugging but we'll call it like that but
what's happening everything is moving in
the universe and everything is
physically connected through the
electromagnetic ropes these twine pair
of threads very thin invisible
untouchable blah blah blah et cetera et
cetera et cetera so everything is in
motion so an atom on the other side of
the universe together with a whole bunch
of atoms that form for example a galaxy
are tugging on a given atom here on
earth any atom so we're being tugged in
every direction from every side of the
universe that's what's tugging on the
atoms and so every atom in the universe
is explaining and contracting in other
words doing its quantum jump the quantum
jump is not a little bead that goes back
and forth between energy levels or
orbitals or whatever nonsense the
quantum mechanics invented no it's that
the
membrane called the electron shell or
electron membrane
expands and contracts that's why it has
these energy levels
and what's compelling them to expand and
contract the fact that everything in the
universe is tugging or influencing them
in some way making them vibrate expand
and contract the whole thing and there
you see all atoms are physically
interconnected is it kind of like having
a
half full balloon
like this kind of how i imagine you have
a half full balloon and you push
the air into one end and then that's
what makes this expand but then when
this one pushes this one to this side
something like that is passing the same
air back and forth something like this
remember
if light travels at a constant speed
meaning that the torsion on the rope is
always the same therefore the the
tension on any rope is always the same
right so there's no different in
tensions between ropes because the speed
of light is the same which is a measure
of that tension then every atom in the
universe is affecting our atom if like
mr
mother says richard muller says
lord and savior mr muller
okay so if everything is physically
connected if everything's pulling on
every atom in your body then the atom on
the other side of the universe is also
somehow influencing your body and it's
all doing it simultaneously across the
entire universe we're affecting them as
well okay so every time oh you're
getting a coping
hey i got vaccinated i should be immune
right i don't know i got vaccinated
twice i don't know maybe
i think i got the chip in me they know
where i am okay another fellow i think
this is the one
god runs the universe with intangible
mediators says who
that may be or may not be true but bill
has no right to make that claim
well what i'm doing is making an
assumption you need to understand the
scientific method the problem is you
don't understand it yet you need an
assumption you have to make an
assumption about the invisible
intangible entities that mother nature
has out there with which she does
phenomena such as magnetism and gravity
which are invisible and intangible we
can't see the mediator right we see an
effect but we don't see the cause okay
and so you have to make an assumption
and you can't go to the lab and say well
i'm going to run an experiment
what experiment you're going to run on
something that's invisible intangible if
you're going to be using your hands and
your eyes to see
the results i like how he says you have
no right to make that claim
i'm not making any clear i'm saying you
have no right good sir to make that clue
i'm not making it here i'm making an
assumption it's called an assumption
okay please understand the language
okay uh foul says here again according
to billy shadow would be an object since
it has shape right here we go again
absolutely not and so it's the same
question yeah yeah okay that's what i'm
saying
i've got these answered uh a shadow
takes two objects three objects at least
okay it takes
the sun in this case in this example the
tree and the ground you need three
objects to make a shadow the shadow
being the fourth object the result if
you want to call it an object because
you think it has shape
no it doesn't have shape because shape
is a standalone thing it's got to be the
only object in the universe when you
point to it in physics there is no other
object not even you okay so the person
stares at an image that was there before
he came into the conference room but i
mean you don't even have to go that far
well i don't know how to make it not
available too but isn't it enough just
to say that a shadow is like a flame
yeah it is but these people don't
understand that that's why i don't know
how far to take this for people to
understand that i'm saying a shadow is
not a i can't have a shadow all by
itself in the middle of nowhere well
because the shadow's a verb right
it's something that's happening it's
created by light which is already a
dynamic entity you know
but so those are the uh issues there
object is the only thing in the universe
that's the only way you can present it
in physics it's must stand alone shadow
is not a standalone object shadow is a
bunch of lights okay
and requires at least two objects uh
really three shadow is a concept and
concepts uh have uh what is a concept
concept is a relation between two
objects okay so
yeah you you can't have a shadow
you can't say a shadow is a physical
object oh yeah but if they do take it to
this level of um
i guess devil's advocacy then
maybe the
word object could use that second
criteria where it isn't a verb
yeah what i what i do is you gotta limit
the definition because people will chop
every single word because their
religions are that state so the extreme
devil's advocate will say oh how about
this and how about that and how do you
define shape and you know they get
involved for most cases the the it
having a shape is enough but for those
fringe cases because it's true
flames do have shape shadows do have
shape but these are these ordinarily
but these are like the the lights on our
screen
there's no shapes there they're really
just
verbs
this is the scanner and again when
you're doing that you're looking at the
observer
it's an observer related
situation that you're presenting no
that's irrelevant no no it is relevant
because i'm saying the following if we
take the light out we take the tv out we
take you out we take everything out we
only leave
what was it the little shape that you
had can that shape subsist all by itself
in the universe without you without
anything without the that's what we're
saying because it's a verb right and my
point is
that's that's the criteria the criterion
is you you take everything out of the
universe and you only leave the the
object you're the alleged object that
you're talking about can you have fire
all by itself can you have [ __ ] can you
have a shadow all by itself well
a better way of saying it is if you zoom
in
is is there shape anymore
also
you'll get to oxygen and carbon yeah but
those are those are the shapes but
there's no shadow there it's just you're
coloring the shapes that are there
exactly if you go into fire if you if
you're god an angel whatever you go all
the way in there what you'll find is
either
oxygen
combusting carbon or whatever it depends
on how much if i zoom into this screen
yeah i'm not going to see these shapes
anymore of course you're going to get
the pixel yeah and not even the pixel i
mean it's a led and yeah what is a pixel
it's a light that's
i guess a better way of putting is with
a shadow you just haven't zoomed in
enough
it's low resolution or a flame or
i like to say i like to say that for the
shadow you need at least three objects
you need the sun or the light the source
whatever you need the object that's
going to stay in the stand in the way
of light you know create the penumbra or
the umber or whatever and then you're
going to have some screen some uh
medium onto which you're going to
project the shadow so you need at least
three objects to this create this
fourth object which you call shadow and
the question is if you take all those
three other objects out can you have a
shadow in the middle of space well maybe
god can do that but we can't you know
shadow is typically
an object an object a shape as if you
want to call it that in ordinary speech
made by three objects yeah i guess i
guess a better way of saying is like
they said here is something that on its
own has shape right it's got to be on
its own okay okay here's another issue
maybe answer some of the ones that uh
they asked there oh yes uh invisible
shape yeah okay i'm getting there i'm
gonna answer your time to have shape how
does he define shape without being
implicitly dependent on using touch and
sight yeah beat that one checkmate no oh
okay so here's the answer object is that
which i shape right and so the fellow
says uh hold it uh don't you need uh
touch and sight
well hopefully the thing has shaped
before you see or touch it
okay so we don't need c or touch
to determine shape shape is what the
cube had what the moon had before any
humans were on board oh and now we're
getting weird so you're saying something
that has shape already headed shape
before you imagine it even before you
imagine already because why did you get
the imagination well you got it from
some some image that you had in the past
okay
now uh
the object has shaped before observer
sees it okay in physics we don't define
shape
that's more important more basic why
don't we define shape because only
devil's advocates whose religion is at
stake
raise the issue of shape what's the
issue the issue is we have to choose a
criterion or criteria
to define the word object for the
purposes of physics because no one has
defined it in the last three thousand
years in a rational manner you mean to
your satisfaction no
we can tear it to pieces very easily
and here we have the seed touch which is
what mathematics use it the religion of
math
uses those
informally see touch because that's what
they find in the dictionary they don't
even know who put it in there maybe some
english major someone who's not has no
stake in physics and they put the seed
touch criteria says well that which you
can see your touch
and so we're comparing shape against see
and touch which criterion are we going
to use that's the issue before us we
don't have to define shape we can take
the word of shape of kindergarten
we can take the word of see touch of
kindergarten we can take the words of
ordinary speech we just need to find out
which criterion we're going to use to
define shape
object for the purposes of physics
that's the question and if we do not use
shape we're going to have to go back to
c touch which is an irrational
definition because it already requires
another object to do the c touching to
begin with i like what you said about
object having shape before the observer
sees
with that you kind of
yeah it's like a precedent to everything
before you even look before you even
determine whether or not
or not before anyone enters the
conference room the image there already
had shape i didn't create the shape with
my eyesight i mean it's the closest
thing we're gonna get to uh a good
definition right anyway shape is a
universal property all objects have
shape it's so so there should be no
quarrel about putting shape as the
criterion to define the word object all
objects have shape if you know of any
object that doesn't have shape please
write to your congress i mean if you
think about it shape is the president to
see and touch things can be seen and
touched because they have shape
exactly otherwise you can't see or touch
them that's essentially what you did you
you took it one step before seeing touch
you're saying before you can see and
touch it
what makes it seeable or touchable
because of that shape because if it
doesn't have shape then it's not there
even the circle has shaped before i
entered the room okay the guy wrote
drew a circle and it already had shape
before i came to the conference there's
no precedent i didn't yeah yeah i i did
not create the circle with my eyesight
or by touching it the the it's almost
like a hierarchy at the bottom of the
hierarchy or at the top of the hierarchy
you say people always put c and touch
but c and touch didn't really it still
has that that step before it which would
be shape because there are some things
some objects that you can't see or touch
but they do our shape yeah it's it's
it's the highest uh
uh thing on the hierarchy there's
nothing you there's no object you can
think of the more
yeah it's the most fundamental i guess
that's the best way to put it i like how
you said it has shape before you
before you can even find out if it does
or not it already does yeah imagine
imagine here's a perfect example the
moon the moon hopefully has shaped
before the asteroid hits it if we're
gonna have to wait for the asteroid to
hit it before we can say the moon has
shaved then we're all in trouble right
okay here's uh
issue of time paul says einstein yeah
because that was raised uh yesterday in
uh
interview a hand einstein general theory
of relativity established time is a
physical thing
physics yeah
it is part of space time time has a
dimension is that a dimension a uh a
physical thing i like how with with that
they they physical time they made
time came in through the back door
this poor fellow he believes that
time is a physical thing he says it's a
dimension dimension is not a physical
thing but he thinks i guess a dimension
is a physical thing so the word length
is a physical thing the word with is a
physical thing because you're losing
your voice
you need a swing of water
okay so he says time is one of the seven
fundamental physical qualities seven
qualities quantity so it's a quality in
a quantity
seven he went straight to seven and it's
physical and so it's gotta be physical
he's gotta put the word physical into
whatever that means you know i don't
know what physical means looks like an
abstraction not physical
time is length of change or the interval
over which change occurs
uh
if if time is an interval a clearly an
interval is not a physical object but
you can draw a physical object bring it
to the conference room and show us how
it's like a rock i mean a rock is a
physical object but to say that an
interval is a physical object what the
hell are you talking about
travel
dilates time
why why did you even bring this guy up
well because these are the things that
people believe in
i mean jesus christ i mean yeah they say
travel dilates time that's what they
tell you it's time yeah so don't travel
because it's gonna stretch your seconds
i guess or whatever five years in a
space
in a ship traveling at 99 the speed of
light corresponds to roughly 36 years on
earth
and the way we do it in science is very
different we say that look the number of
times
that the earth went around the time was
either 36 years or something else
if it was 36 years we don't care how
fast the other guy traveled and where he
went and when he went when he comes back
hopefully the number of times
36 times around the earth the uh sun
that's how many times the earth went
around and so
you can't have it two ways either win
around 36 times or more or less it can't
be
both okay so period we're done with that
okay i mean according to that logic
flight attendants live longer
because they travel
okay so here we have uh another issue
paul says the difference between
microscopic and invisible atoms in the
air are microscopic not invisible well
this poor fellow is convinced confusing
microscopic with
invisibility okay uh
he's getting these things mixed up
because he's putting the observer in
there microscopic just means small has
nothing to do with whether you can see
or not okay blind man can't see either
one small or big so it doesn't matter
invisibility has to do with seeing
so to compare microscopic with
invisibility is already irrational okay
so please get your brain back i don't
know what the context is but it is a
good distinction to make between
microscopic and invisible right yeah
because i mean he's confusing he's
saying that
essentially he's saying that
the fact that it's microscopic doesn't
mean it's invisible i'm saying that one
has nothing to do with the other you
cannot gauge microscopic by the word
invisibility invisibility means that you
can't see
and uh invisibility is what a blind man
has you know he's invisible
that'd be pretty cool
visible means he can't see he's
invisible or invisible or whatever and
microscopy just means small so one thing
has nothing to do with the other
and then he says only concepts are
invisible and intangible okay can you
see the air
is air a concept or a physical object is
air made out of atoms can you breathe it
is there air enveloping the earth is
there air inside the balloon but it's
tangible
yeah but i mean you should have said
only concepts well but it doesn't matter
my point is how careless he is in his
reasoning you know uh air we cannot see
is an air is not a concept air is a
physical object okay air is what blew
down your house when it turned into
storm air under water i guess that's a
good point and uh can you uh touch the
aussie's chair on the other side of the
planet maybe he is obviously
okay can he see that kind of
what if he's on there can you touch the
americans uh chair over there you know i
mean the fact that you cannot see his
chair or touch the chair because you're
on the other side of the planet or or on
the other side of the universe the
klingons tear can you touch his tear so
see and touch is what you have to
eliminate from your vocabulary
and touchable is what they actually mean
that's that's so before seeing touch you
got seeable and touchable before you got
seeable untouchable you got shape and
and the issue is they always want to
introduce the observer they want to
introduce experiment and you can't
introduce an experiment you cannot
introduce observer with mother nature's
invisible intangible mediators that's
the issue
we have no use for experiments
not in the context of the use well not
for uh with the mediator of gravity what
are you going to put for the mediator
what are you going to find in the lab
you dropped the pencil yeah the pencil i
can i see
it's good to know that it doesn't go up
it gives you some clues
well maybe there's no strings attached
you know
okay an object must be visible in order
to have shape absolutely not okay and
there are objects which have shape which
we cannot see as the quantum guys they
say that
the gluons
are things they say they're point
particles but they call them particles
meaning they're something and they can't
see or touch them so i don't know if you
can use that criterion but anyways uh
yeah there are objects we cannot see or
touch the air is one of them uh the
object the
rock on the other side magnetism is a
good one gravity's a good one yeah and
they're objects there's something there
okay
if something is invisible its existence
would be unfalsifiable well existence it
has nothing to do with visibility or
tangibility and vice falsifiability has
to do with religion you are into
religion fellow you're not into science
so don't talk about proving don't talk
about what you believe what gives you
the right to make that claim i'm going
to say that i love that line
okay and finally what degrees do you
have
here's the other here's the other final
issue mass and weight are not the same
hey that's true uh grab with the black
holes right it it crushes the mass out
but keeps the weight yep yep it keeps
the weight because uh they call it the
mass okay but no mass and weight are
synonym perfect synonyms and let me tell
you why a couple reasons at least i've
gone over that in the past but you know
mass
whenever they say what is your mass or
how much mass is there they give you
yeah they give you the value in
kilograms or pounds or some some
measurement like that
and if mass is the quantity of matter
they should be telling you it's one
trillion atoms
or a gazillion atoms or whatever they
should give you a number followed by
it's a quantity it's an amount they
should not give you a measurement but
see mass is always given to you as a
measurement they never tell you how many
atoms or how many units of mass
something has so you take uh i don't
know a rock you weight on earth it
weighs one kilogram here on earth you
take it to the moon so people say well
the weight changed but the mass remained
the same
absolutely not the mass change because
we're gonna the way we're gonna
determine it is by weighing it on the
moon and we're going to give you the
value in kilograms or pounds or whatever
you measured it here on earth and so
it's going to weigh what 1 6 less on the
moon
and and so we're going to say that here
on earth the mass was 1 kilogram and
over there it was uh what is it one six
point sixteen kilogram and what have we
learned uh we learned the weight that's
all we have but it isn't all you're
saying that
we're just not sticking to our
definition because if our definition is
quantity of matter and we counted it
we'd have no problem with with the moon
or the earth it'd be the same number
yeah the problem is they can't do it see
they oh yeah that's a difference let me
tell you why they can't do it see
there's a reason for why they can't do
it see the the special relativity says
that
when an object accelerates near the
speed of light okay
its mass increases it has more atoms ah
did it have more atoms or is it pressing
harder on the on the scale that's the
question if it presses harder on the
scale which is what they're insinuating
known as relativistic mass they're
talking about weight they're talking
about the pressure it causes
on the scale and if they're talking
about quantity of matter
his question is on the money did the
thing increase in number of atoms in the
rock as it approached the speed of
light did it increase the number of
atoms or is it was just pressing harder
because of its speed was it pressing
harder on the scale but if we could
count the atoms would that solve the
issue well the question is well that's a
good question i mean
again did the number of atoms increase
or no that's just throwing the ball on
the weight is right that's how the scale
is different than
placing it on there but that's all they
said count that's not a special raw tip
yeah but if you can count the atoms then
mass would be different from weight yeah
we would think that an object that
travels at the speed of light or close
to the speed of light right 99 from
whatever speed of light
the number of atoms it has so far
haven't changed you haven't made that
assumption at least it's just really
fast it's just moving faster so what are
you talking about you're talking about
weight you're talking about the pressure
on the scale
and that's all that's why mass and
weight are exactly the same until the
mathematicians are able to separate
first mass from weight first of all
and second until they define it in such
a way that they don't use it as weight
anytime they want to like in
relativistic mass well that's the thing
that just shows how how they play
semantics with or they
they play fast and loose with their
definitions they on the one hand say
quantity of matter but then they start
using weight which has nothing to do
with quantity matter right
right and that's what special relativity
is they're talking about weight they
never figured it out
anyways do we have any other no i've
been asking him as we as we went okay
okay folks then we'll see you next
sunday and thank you for being on board
today yeah it was fun
we'll see you next time bye bye